This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The peak of summer usually means time spent outdoors, the mountains, the beach. And for those of us who spent most of the past 15 months within the confines of our homes, getting out feels more urgent than ever. But as wildfire smoke cloaks the American West, blizzards, lash Australia, and deadly droughts strikes South Africa and Madagascar. You might feel like turning right around and going back inside. Scientists have been warning us for years about the looming threat of a warming planet.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。盛夏通常意味着要在户外度过，去高地，去海滩。对于我们这些在过去15个月里大部分时间闭门不出的人来说，出门的愿望比以往任何时候都更加迫切。然而，随着野火烟雾笼罩美国西部，暴风雪肆虐澳大利亚，致命的干旱袭击南非和马达加斯加，你可能会萌生转头回屋的念头。多年来，科学家一直在警告我们，地球变暖正带来迫在眉睫的威胁。
And yet it's really hard for many of us to wrap our minds around this existential threat. Why is that? This week on Hidden Brain, a favorite episode where we visit the glaciers of Alaska to find out why our brains struggle to grasp the imminent dangers of global climate change? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedaantam. Last year, my family and I took a vacation to Alaska. This was a much needed, long planned break. The best part? I got to walk on the top of a glacier. The pale blue ice was translucent.
然而，我们中的许多人还是很难真正理解这一生存威胁。这是为什么呢？本周的《隐藏的大脑》为您奉上一期精彩节目，我们将带您探访阿拉斯加的冰川，去探究为什么我们的大脑很难意识到全球气候变化迫在眉睫的危险？这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。去年，我和家人去阿拉斯加度假。这是一次期待已久、急需的放松之旅。最棒的部分是什么呢？我有幸走在了一座冰川的顶端。那淡蓝色的冰晶莹剔透。
Sharp ridges opened up into crevices dozens of feet deep. Every geological feature, every hill, every valley, was sculpted in ice. It was a sunny day and I spotted a small stream of melted water. I got on the ground and drank some. I wondered how long this water had remained frozen. The little stream is not the only ice that's melting in Alaska. The Mendenhall Glacier, one of the chief tourist attractions in Juneau, has retreated over one and a half miles in the last half century. Today you can only see a small sliver of the glacier's tongue from a lookout. I caught up with John Neary, a forest service official who tries to explain to visitors
尖锐的山脊裂开，形成几十英尺深的冰缝。每一个地质特征、每一座小山、每一条山谷，都是由冰雕琢而成的。那天阳光明媚，我发现了一条融水汇成的小溪。我趴在地上喝了一些。我在想，这些水究竟被冻结了多久。这条小溪并不是阿拉斯加唯一在融化的冰。门登霍尔冰川是朱诺主要的旅游景点之一，在过去半个世纪里已经后退了英里半以上。如今，你只能从观景台上看到冰川舌的一小部分。我采访了约翰·尼里，他是一名森林服务局官员，负责向游客解释
the scale of the changes that they're witnessing. I would say that right now we're looking at a glacier that's filling up out of our 180 degree view we have. We're looking at maybe 10 or 15 degrees of it. Whereas if we stood in the same place 100 years ago, it would have filled up about 160 degrees of our view. You are kidding, 160 degrees of our view? Exactly. That's the reality of how big this was. And it's been retreating up this valley at about 40 or 50 feet a year, most recently 400 feet a year. And even more dramatically recently is the thinning and the narrowing as it's just sort of collapsed in on itself in the bottom of this valley.
他们所目睹的变化规模。我想说，现在我们看到的冰川，在我们拥有的一百八十度视野中，大概只占了十度或十五度。而如果我们一百年前站在同一个地方，它会占据我们大约一百六十度的视野。你在开玩笑吧，占了我们视野的一百六十度？一点没错。这就是它曾经有多大的真实写照。它正以每年大约四十到五十英尺的速度向这条山谷上方退缩，最近更是达到了每年四百英尺。更戏剧性的是，最近它开始变薄、变窄，就像在这条山谷底部自行坍塌了一样。
Instead of dominating much of the valley and being able to see white eyes out a large portion of the landscape, it's now becoming this littleden that's at the bottom. John is a quiet soft-spoken man. In recent years, as he's watched the glacier literally recede before his eyes, he started to speak up. Not just about what's happening, but what it means. But as I was chatting with John, a visitor came up to talk to him. The man said he used to serve in the Air Force and had last seen the Mendenhall Glacier a quarter century ago.
它不再占据山谷的大部分面积，让你在大部分风景中都能看到白色的冰川，现在它变成了一个位于底部的孤立小冰块。约翰是一个安静、说话温和的人。近年来，当他眼睁睁地看着冰川实实在在地后退时，他开始发声。不仅是为了讲述正在发生的事情，更是为了阐明这意味着什么。但正当我与约翰交谈时，一位游客走过来和他说话。那个人说他曾在空军服役，上一次看到门登霍尔冰川还是在四分之一世纪前。
There was a look in the man's eyes. It was a combination of all and horror. How could this have happened, the man asked John, why is this happening? In many ways people don't want to grasp the reality. It's a scary reality to try to grasp. And so what they naturally want to do is assume, well, this has always happened. It will happen in the future and will survive, won't we?
那个人的眼神里流露出一种复杂的情绪。那是敬畏与惊恐的交织。这怎么可能发生？那个人问约翰，为什么会这样？在许多情况下，人们并不想接受现实。这是一个试图去理解就会感到害怕的现实。因此，他们自然而然会想去假设，好吧，这种事一直都在发生。未来它还会发生，我们也会活下来，不是吗？
They want an assurance from me. But I don't give it to them. I don't think it's my job to give them that assurance. I think they need to grasp the reality of the fact that we are entering into a time when yes, glacial advance in retreat has happened 25 different times to North America over its long life, but never at the rate and the scale that we see now, and in the very quick rapidity of it means that species probably won't be able to adapt the way that they have in the past over a longer period
他们想要从我这里得到一个保证。但我不会给他们。我认为这不是我的工作去给他们这种保证。我认为他们需要正视这样一个事实，即我们正在进入这样一个时代：是的，在其漫长的生命中，北美洲曾经历过25次冰川的前进与后退，但其速度和规模从未像现在这样，而且这种极快的速率意味着物种可能无法像过去那样在更长的时间内
of time. To be clear, the Mendenhall Glacier's retreat, in and of itself, is not proof of climate change. That evidence comes from a range of scientific measurements and calculations. But the glacier is a visible symbol of the changes that scientists are documenting. It's interesting, I think, when people think about climate
进行适应。需要明确的是，门登霍尔冰川的后退本身并不是气候变化的证据。这些证据来自于一系列科学测量和计算。但这座冰川是科学家们正在记录的变化的一个具象符号。我想这很有趣，当人们思考气候
change, it tends to be an abstract issue most of the time for most people that you're standing in front of this magnificent glacier right now and to actually see it receding makes it feel real and visceral in a way that it just isn't when I'm living in Washington DC. Oh, I agree. I think that for too many people the issue is some Micronesian island that's having an extra inch of water this year on their shorelines or it's some polar bears far up in the Arctic that they're really not connected with but when they realize they come here and they're on this nice day like we're experienced
变化时，对大多数人来说，它在大多数时候往往是一个抽象的问题，而你此刻正站这座壮丽的冰川前，亲眼看着它后退，这种真实感和直观感受是住在华盛顿特区的我所无法体会到的。哦，我完全赞同。我认为对太多人来说，这个问题不过是某个密克罗尼西亚岛屿今年海岸线上多了一英寸的水，或者是远在北极、与他们毫无关系的几只北熊，但当他们意识到自己来到了这里，在这个像我们现在这样经历着的阳光温暖的美好日子里
right now with the warm sun they start to think about this glacier melting and why it's receding why it's disappearing why it doesn't look like that photo just 30 years ago up in the visitor center it becomes real for them and they have to start grapple with the issues behind it. I could see tourists turning these questions over in their minds as they watch the glacier. So even though I had not planned to do any reporting, I started interviewing people using the only device I had available, my phone. This is Dale Singer. She and her family came to Alaska on a cruise to celebrate a couple of family birthdays.
开始思考这座冰川为什么在融化，为什么在后退，为什么在消失，为什么它看起来不像游客中心里仅仅三十年前的那张照片时，这一切对他们来说就变得真实了，他们不得不开始认真对待背后的问题。我看着游客们在观赏冰川时，脑海中不断翻滚着这些问题。因此，尽管我本来没有做任何采访的计划，我还是开始用身边唯一的设备——我的手机——采访人们。这位是戴尔·辛格。她和家人乘游轮来到阿拉斯加，是为了庆祝几位家庭成员的生日。
This was her second trip to Mendenhall. She came about nine years ago, but the weather was so foggy, she couldn't get a good look. She felt compelled to come back. I asked Dale why she thought the glacier was retreating. Global warming, whether we like to admit it or not, it's our fault or something we're doing is effect and climate change. Others are not so sure. For some of Dale's fellow passengers on her cruise, this is a touchy topic. Somebody just said they went to a lecture on the ship
这是她第二次来到门登霍尔。她大约九年前来过，但当时雾太大，她没能看清。她觉得自己必须要回来看看。我问戴尔为什么她认为冰川在后退。全球变暖，不管我们愿不愿意承认，这就是我们的错，或者是我们正在做的事情所带来的影响和气候变化。其他人则没有那么确定。对于戴尔游轮上的某些同伴来说，这是一个敏感的话题。有人刚刚说他们去听了一场船上的讲座
and the lecturer did not use the word global warming nor climate change because he didn't want to offend passengers. So there are still people who refuse to admit it. I caught up with another tourist. I asked Michael Bull if he believed climate change was real. No, I think there's global climate change, but I question whether it's all due to human interaction with the earth. Yes, you can't deny that the climate is changing. But the causation of that, I'm not sold on as being our fault. Michael was worried his tour bus might leave without him,
而讲师没有使用“全球变暖”这个词，也没有使用“气候变化”，因为他不想冒犯乘客。所以仍然有人拒绝承认这一点。我采访了另一位游客。我问迈克尔·布尔是否相信气候变化是真实的。不，我认为存在全球气候变化，但我怀疑这是否全是由人类与地球的互动引起的。是的，你无法否认气候正在变化。但其起因是否是我们的错，我并不买账。迈克尔担心他的旅游大巴可能会不等他就开走，
so he answered my question about whether the glacier's retreat was cause for alarm, standing next to the idling bus. So what's the bad part of the glacier receiving? And you know, from what John said to me, if it's the rate at which and the Earth can't adapt, that makes sense to me. But I think the final story is yet to be written. I think Mother Earth pushes back.
于是他站在空转的汽车旁，回答了我关于冰川后退是否值得警惕的问题。那么，冰川后退有什么不好的地方呢？你知道的，从约翰对我说的话来看，如果这是地球无法适应的速度，那这对我来说是有道理的。但我认为最终的故事尚未写完。我认为大地母亲会进行反击。
So I don't think we're going to destroy her because I think she'll take care of us before we take care of her. Nucket Falls is a beautiful waterfall that empties into Mendenhall Lake. When John first came to Alaska in 1982, the waterfall was adjacent to the glacier. Today there's a gap of three quarters of a mile between the waterfall and the glacier. The glacier has receded unbelievably. It's quite shocking. This is Sue Schultz. She said she lived in June or back in the 1980s. This was her first time back in 28 years.
所以我不认为我们会毁灭她，因为我认为在我们照顾她之前，她会照顾我们的。纳吉特瀑布是一个美丽的瀑布，注入门登霍尔湖。1982年约翰刚来到阿拉斯加时，瀑布与冰川是相邻的。如今，瀑布和冰川之间有四分之三英里的间隔。冰川后退得令人难以置信。这相当令人震惊。这是苏·舒尔茨。她说她曾在20世纪80年代住在朱诺。这是她时隔28年第一次回来。
What did it look like 28 years ago? The bear rock that you see to the left, as you face the glacier, was glacier. And we used to hike on the other side of it. You could take a trail right onto the glacier. And what about this way? I understand the glacier actually came significantly over to this side close to nugget falls. Yes, that's true. It was really close. In fact, the lake was a lot smaller, obviously. I mean, yeah, it's quite incredible. And so what's your reaction when you see it? Global warming.
28年前这里是什么样子的？当你面向冰川时，左边看到的裸露岩石以前都是冰川。我们过去常在它的另一侧徒步。你可以顺着一条小径直接走到冰川上。那这边呢？我听说冰川曾经显著地延伸到这一侧，靠近纳吉特瀑布。是的，确实如此。它真的非常近。事实上，湖泊要小得多，很明显。我是说，是的，这相当不可思议。那么当你看到它时，你的反应是什么？全球变暖。
We need to pay attention. Even if it all melts, it's not going to be the end of the world. So I'm not worried. Terry Lambert is a tourist from Southern California. He's never visited Mendenhall before. He thinks the melting glacier is just part of nature's plan. While it's just like earthquakes and floods and hurricanes, there are just all part of what's going on.
我们需要予以关注。即使它全部融化了，也不会是世界末日。所以我并不担心。特里·兰伯特是来自南加州的游客。他以前从未参观过门登霍尔。他认为冰川融化只是自然计划的一部分。这就像地震、洪水和飓风一样，它们都是正在发生的事情的一部分。
You can't control it, you can't change it. And I personally don't think it's something that man's doing that's making that melt. I mentioned to Terry, some of the possible consequences of climate change on various species. Well, there could be changes, some species could be advantage, some species could be disadvantaged. The ecosystem is changing, you're going to have flooding,
你无法控制它，你无法改变它。我个人不认为这是人类造成的融化。我向特里提到了气候变化对各种物种的一些可能影响。嗯，可能会有变化，有些物种可能会占优势，有些物种可能会处于劣势。生态系统正在改变，你会经历洪水，
you could have weather events, right? There could be consequences that affect you and I. Yes, but like I say, it's so far in the future, I'm not worried about it. I realized at that moment that the debate over climate change is no longer really about science, unless the science you're talking about is the study of human behavior. I asked John why he thought so many people were unwilling to accept the scientific consensus the climate change was having real consequences. The inability to do anything about it themselves, because it's threatening to think about giving
你可能会遭遇极端天气事件，对吧？可能会产生影响你我的后果。是的，但就像我说的，那太遥远了，我不担心。那一刻我意识到，关于气候变化的争论实际上已经不再是关于科学，除非你所说的科学是对人类行为的研究。我问约翰，为什么他认为这么多人不愿意接受“气候变化正在产生真正后果”这一科学共识。他们自己无力采取任何行动，因为一想到要放弃
up your car, giving up your oil heater in your house, or giving up many of the things that you've become accustomed to, they seem very threatening to them. And really, I've looked at some of the brain science actually and talked to folks at NASA, North and Sky, and they've actually talked about how when that fear becomes overriding for people, they use a part of their brain. That's the very primitive part that has to react. It has to instantly come to a conclusion so that it can lead to an action. Whereas what we need to think about is get rid of that fear and start thinking logically, start thinking creatively, allow a different part of the brain to kick in, and really think
你的汽车，放弃你家里的燃油暖气，或者放弃许多你已经习惯了的东西，这些对他们来说似乎具有很大的威胁性。实际上，我研究过一些大脑科学，也和美国宇航局（NASA）以及“天空北方”（North and Sky）的人聊过，他们实际上讨论过，当这种恐惧对人们来说变得压倒一切时，他们就会使用大脑的一个部分。那是必须作出反应的最原始的部分。它必须瞬间得出结论，以便引导采取行动。然而，我们需要思考的是，摆脱这种恐惧，开始进行逻辑思考，开始进行创造性思考，让大脑的不同部分发挥作用，并真正思考
how we as humans can reverse this trend that we've caused. Coming up, we explore why the human brain might not be well designed to grapple with a threat of climate change and what we can do about it. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. While visiting the Mendenhall Glacier with my family last year, I started thinking more and more about the intersection between climate change and human behavior. When I got back to Washington DC, I called George Marshall.
我们人类该如何扭转我们所造成的这种趋势。接下来，我们将探讨为什么人脑可能并不适合应对气候变化的威胁，以及我们能做些什么。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。去年和家人参观门登霍尔冰川时，我越来越多地思考气候变化与人类行为之间的交集。回到华盛顿特区后，我打电话给乔治·马歇尔。
He's an environmentalist who, like John Neary, tries to educate people about global climate change. As the book's title suggests, George believes that the biggest roadblock in the battle against climate change may lie inside the human brain. I call George at his home in Wales. You spent some time talking with Daniel Kahneman, the famous psychologist who won the Nobel Prize in Economics, and he actually presented a very pessimistic view that we would actually come to terms with the threat of climate change. He said to me that we are as humans very poor at dealing with issues, whether in the future
他是一位环保主义者，和约翰·尼里一样，致力于向人们普及全球气候变化知识。正如书名所示，乔治认为，应对气候变化之战中最大的绊脚石可能就存在于人类的大脑之中。我在他位于威尔士的家中给他打了电话。你曾花时间与丹尼尔·卡尼曼交谈过，他是获得诺贝尔经济学奖的著名心理学家，他实际上提出了一个非常悲观的观点，即我们实际上很难接受气候变化的威胁。他对我说，我们人类非常不擅长处理问题，无论是在未来
we tend to be very focused on a short term. We tend to discount, would be the economic term, to reduce the value of things happening in the future, but further away they are. He says we're very cost-averse, let's first of all say, when there is a reward we respond strongly, but when there's a cost we prefer to push it away, just as I myself would try and leave until the very last minute, you have been in my tax return, I mean you just don't want to deal with these things. And he says we're reluctant to deal with uncertainty, if things are uncertain we or we perceive them to be, we just say well come back and tell me when they're certain. What he said to me was in his view of a climate
我们往往非常关注短期。用经济学的术语来说，我们往往会贴现，也就是降低未来发生的事情的价值，它们距离越远，价值就越低。他说我们对成本非常厌恶，首先来说，当有回报时我们会强烈回应，但当有代价时我们更倾向于把它推开，就像我自己也会尽量把报税拖到最后一分钟一样，你一定也填过报税单，我的意思是，人们就是不想处理这些事情。他说我们不愿意面对不确定性，如果事情是不确定的，或者我们认为是不确定的，我们就会说，好吧，等确定了再来告诉我。他对我说，在他看来，气候
change is the worst possible combination because it's not only in the future, but it's also in the future and uncertain, and it's in the future uncertain and involving costs. And his own experiments, and he's done many, many of these over the years, show that in this combination, we have a very strong tendency just to push things on one side. And I think this in some ways explains how so many people, if you ask them, we'll say, yes, I regard climate change to be a threat. But if you go and you ask them, and this happens every year, and in surveys, what are the most important issues, strangely almost everybody seems to forget about climate change.
变化是最糟糕的组合，因为它不仅发生在未来，而且还是未来的、不确定的，并且是未来的、不确定的且涉及成本的。他自己的实验——这些年来他做过非常非常多的实验——表明，在这种组合下，我们有一种非常强烈的倾向，就是把事情放到一边。我认为这在某种程度上解释了为什么许多人在被问到时会说，是的，我认为气候变化是一个威胁。但如果你去问他们——这每年都会在民意调查中发生——最重要的问题是什么，奇怪的是，几乎每个人似乎都把气候变化忘得精光。
So when we focus on it, we know it's there, but we can somehow push it away. You tell an amusing story in your book about some colleagues who are worried about a cell phone tower being erected in their neighborhood and the very, very different reaction of these colleagues to the cell phone tower than to sort of the amorphous threat of climate change. My neighbor's, my entire community, I was living at that time in Oxford, which as many of you listen to us and know is a university talent, so I'd be like living in Harvard or Berkeley or somewhere where most of the people were in various ways involved of university, highly educated, a mobile phone, master's being set up in the middle,
所以当我们关注它时，我们知道它在那里，但不知何故我们还是能把它推开。你在书中讲了一个有趣的故事，讲到一些同事担心他们的社区里要竖起一座手机信号塔，而这些同事对手机信号塔的反应，与对气候变化那种无形威胁的反应截然不同。我的邻居，我的整个社区，我当时住在牛津，正如你们许多听众所知，那是一个大学城，所以就像住在哈佛或伯克利之类的地方，那里大多数人在某种程度上都与大学有关，受过高等教育，一个移动电话
alongside actually a school playground, enormous outcry,cry everybody mobilized down the local church hall They were all gonna stop it people even gonna lay themselves down in front of a bulldozer to prevent it Because it was here it was now there was an enemy which was this external mobile phone company We're gonna come in. They were gonna put up this mask. It brings in the threat psychologist would call the absolute fear of radiation. This is what's called a dread fear. Now, the science, if we go back to the core science, says that this mobile phone mask was as
桅杆正要建在中间，甚至紧挨着一所学校的游乐场，引发了巨大的抗议。每个人都动员起来聚集到当地的教堂大厅，他们都打算阻止它，人们甚至打算躺在推土机前阻止它，因为它就在这里，它就在现在，有一个敌人，那就是这个要进驻的外部移动电话公司。他们要竖起这个桅杆。这就带来了心理学家所说的对辐射的绝对恐惧。这就是所谓的恐惧。现在，如果我们回到核心科学来看，科学表明这个移动手机桅杆
far as we could possibly say harmless. You know, they're not a radiation or of any kind. You get off a single mobile phone mask, has never been found to have the slightest impact on anyone but they were very mobilized. At the same time I was trying to get them to attend events concerned of climate change and the amount of them would come. It simply didn't have those qualities. You have a very revealing anecdote in your book about the economist Thomas Shelling who was once in a major traffic jam.
就我们所能确定的而言是无害的。你知道的，它们根本不是什么辐射源。人们发现单一的移动手机桅杆从未对任何人产生过丝毫影响，但他们却被极大地动员了起来。与此同时，我试图让他们参加关注气候变化的活动，但来的人寥寥无几。它根本不具备那些特质。你的书里有一个非常具有启发性的轶事，讲的是经济学家托马斯·谢林有一次遇到了大塞车。
So, shelling again, Nobel Prize winning economist, and he's wondering what's going on. The traffic is moving very, very, very slowly, and then they're creeping along and creeping along and half an hour along the road. They finally realize what has happened, that there's a mattress lying right in the middle of the lane of the road. What happens, he notices, and he does the same. When they reach for mattress, people will simply drive, pass it, and keep going. In other words, the thing that
所以，还是谢林，这位诺贝尔奖得主经济学家，他在纳闷发生了什么。车流移动得非常非常非常缓慢，然后他们一点点地挪动，在路上花了半个小时。他们终于意识到发生了什么，原来路中间的正中央躺着一个床垫。他注意到，接下来发生的事情是，当他们到达床垫旁时，人们只是开车绕过它，然后继续前行。换句话说，那个
caused them to become delayed was not something that anyone was prepared to stop and remove from the road. They just leave the mattress there and then they keep driving past. Because in a way, why would they remove the mattress from the road because they have already paid the price of getting there, they've already had the delay? It's something where the benefit goes to other people. The argument being that of course it's very hard, especially when people are motivated largely through personal rewards to get them to do things. It's interesting that the same narrative affects the way we talk about climate change internationally. There are many countries who now say, look, I've already paid the price.
导致他们延误的东西，并没有让任何人准备好停下来把它从路上移走。他们只是把床垫留在那里，然后继续开车驶过。因为从某种程度上说，他们为什么要从路上移走床垫呢，既然他们已经付出了到达那里的代价，已经经历了延误？这是一个利益归于其他人的事情。这个论点表明，当然这非常困难，特别是当人们主要受到个人奖励的驱动时，要让他们去做这些事情。有趣的是，同样的叙事也影响了我们国际上谈论气候变化的方式。现在有许多国家说，看，我已经付出了代价。
I'm paying the price right now for the actions of other people, for the things that other people have or have not done. I'm bearing that cost. You're asking me now to get out of my car, pull the mattress off the road to bear an additional cost, and the only people who benefit from that are people who are not me. The collective problems in the end have personal consequences. I have to say that the way that one talks about this also shows the way that interpretation is biased by your own politics or your own view. This has been labeled for a long time the tragedy of the commons. The idea being that people will, if it's in their own self-interest, destroy the very thing that sustains them because it's not in their
我正在为其他人的行为、为其他人做过或没有做过的事情付出代价。我正在承担这个代价。你现在要求我下车，把床垫从路上移开，去承担额外的代价，而唯一从中受益的人却不是我。这些集体问题最终都会带来个人的后果。我必须说，人们谈论这件事的方式也表明，这种解释会受到你自己的政治立场或观点的影响。长期以来，这被称为公地悲剧。这种观念认为，如果符合他们自身的利益，人们就会摧毁维持他们生存的东西，因为如果他们看不到其他人这样做，做这件事就不符合他们的
personal interest to do something if they don't see other people doing it. In a way it's understandable but of course that depends on a view of a world where you see people has been motivated entirely by their own personal rewards. We also know that people are motivated by their sense of identity and their sense of belonging and we know very well I'm not least of all in times of major conflict or war that people are prepared to make enormous personal sacrifices from which they personally derive nothing except loss. But they're making that in the interests of the greater good.
个人利益。在某种程度上这是可以理解的，但当然，这取决于这样一种世界观：你认为人们的动机完全是由他们自己的个人利益驱动的。我们也知道，人们的动机还受到他们的身份认同感和归属感的驱动，我们非常清楚，尤其是在重大冲突或战争时期，人们准备做出巨大的个人牺牲，而他们从这些牺牲中个人得不到任何东西，只有损失。但他们是为了更宏大的利益而做出这种牺牲的。
For a long time with climate change, we've made a mistake of talking about this solely in terms of something which is economic. What the economic cost and what of economic benefits and we still do this but of course really for motivations for why we want to act on this is what we want to defend the world what we care about and the world we love and we want to do so for ourselves and for the people who are going to come. So George there obviously is one domain in life where you can see people constantly placing these sacred values above their selfish self-interest. I'm thinking here about the many, many religions we have in the world that get people to do all
长期以来，在气候变化问题上，我们犯了一个错误，那就是完全从经济的角度来谈论它。什么是经济成本，什么是经济效益，我们现在仍然这样做，但当然，我们想要采取行动的真正动机，是我们想要保卫我们所关心的世界，我们所热爱的世界，我们希望为自己以及为将要到来的人们这样做。所以，乔治，生活中显然有一个领域，在那里你可以看到人们不断将这些神圣的价值置于他们的自私利益之上。我在这里想到的是我们世界上的许许多多宗教，它们让人去做各种
kinds of things that an economist would say is not in their rational self-interest. People give up food, people give up water, people have, you know, suffer enormous personal privations, people sometimes choose chastity for life. I mean, huge costs that people are willing to bear, and they're not doing it because someone says at the end of the year, I'm going to give you an extra 200 bucks in your paycheck or an extra $2,000 in your paycheck. They're doing it because they believe these are sacred values that are not negotiable. Well, and not just economists would find those behavioural strange, but Professor Karneman or pure cognitive psychology might as well, because these are people who are struggling with but also believe passionately in things which are in the long term extremely uncertain and require personal
经济学家会认为不符合其理性自愿利益的事情。人们放弃食物，人们放弃水，人们经历（你知道的）巨大的个人剥夺，人们有时选择终身守贞。我的意思是，人们愿意承受巨大的代价，而他们这样做并不是因为有人在年底时对他们的工资单说，我要给你额外200块钱或者2000美元。他们这样做是因为他们相信这些是不容协商的神圣价值观。嗯，不仅经济学家会觉得这些行为奇怪，卡尼曼教授或纯认知心理学也会觉得奇怪，因为这些人正在与某些事物抗争，但同时也坚信那些在长期来看极其不确定且需要个人
cost. And yet people do so. It's very important to stress that when we try and when we talk about climate change and religion that there's absolutely no sense at all that climate change is or can or should ever be like a religion, it's not, it's grounded in science. But we can also learn, I think, a great deal from religions about how to approach these issues, these uncertain issues and how to create, I think, a community of shared belief and shared conviction that something is important. Right. If you look at human history with the broad view, you don't actually have to be a religious person to acknowledge that religion has played a very, very important role in the lives of millions of people over thousands of years. And if it's done so, then a scientific approach would say there is something about the nature of religious belief or the practice of religion that harnesses what our brains can accommodate, that the
付出代价的事情。然而人们还是这样做了。非常重要的一点是要强调，当我们尝试谈论气候变化与宗教时，绝对没有任何意义认为气候变化是、可以或应该像一种宗教，它不是，它扎根于科学。但我想我们也可以从宗教那里学到很多东西，关于如何对待这些问题，这些不确定问题，以及如何建立一个共同信仰和共同信念的社区，让大家觉得某件事很重要。没错。如果你用宏观的视角来看人类历史，你其实不需要是一个宗教人士去承认宗教在数千年里数百万人的生活中发挥了非常非常重要的作用。如果它确实如此，那么科学的方法就会说，宗教信仰的本质或宗教的实践中存在着某种东西，它利用了我们大脑所能包容的特质，利用了
harness are yearning to be part of a tribe, are yearning to be connected to deeper and grander values than ourselves, are yearning in some ways to do things for our fellow person in a way that might not be tangible in the here and now, but might actually pay off, as you say, not just for future generations, but even in the year after. Well, and the faiths that dominate, the half a dozen faiths which are the strongest ones in the world are the ones that have been best at doing that. There's a big mistake with climate change because it comes from science, but we assume
我们渴望成为部落一部分的渴望，渴望与比我们自己更深邃、更宏大的价值观建立连接的渴望，某种程度上渴望为我们的同胞做一些事情的渴望——这些事情在此时此地可能并非有形的，但正如你所说，可能真的会有所回报，不仅为后代，甚至在一年之后也是如此。嗯，那些占主导地位的信仰，世界上最强大的那半打信仰，就是最擅长做到这一点的信仰。在气候变化问题上有一个巨大的错误，因为它是从科学中产生的，但我们假设
it just somehow soaks into us. It's very clear that just hitting people over their head with more and more and more data and graphs isn't working. On my internet feeds, I'm on all of the main scientific feeds. There is a new paper every day that says that, not only is it bad, but it's worse than we thought. And it's extremely, extremely serious, so serious actually we're finding it very hard even to find the words to describe it. That doesn't move people in fact actually it tends to push them away. However, if we can understand that there are other things which bind us together I think that we can find
它会不知何故自然而然地渗入我们心中。很明显，用越来越多的数据和图表不断地敲打人们的头脑是没有用的。在我的互联网动态中，我订阅了所有主要的科学动态。每天都有一篇新论文说，不仅情况很糟糕，而且比我们想象的还要糟糕。而且情况非常非常严重，实际上严重到我们甚至很难找到词语来描述它。这并不能打动人，事实上，它往往会把人推开。然而，如果我们能够理解还有其他东西将我们紧密联系在一起，我想我们可以找到
new language. I think it's also very important to recognize that the divides around climate change are social, not scientific. They're social and political, that the single biggest determinants of whether you accept it or you don't accept it is your political values. And that suggests that the solutions to this are not scientific, other than maybe psychology. They are cultural. We have to find ways of saying sure. We're going to disagree on things politically, but we have things in common that we all care about
新的语言。我认为同样非常重要的一点是认识到，围绕气候变化的裂痕是社会的，而不是科学的。它们是社会和政治的，决定你是否接受它的最主要因素是你的政治价值观。这表明，除了心理学之外，解决这些问题的方案不是科学的。它们是文化的。我们必须找到表达方式：当然。我们在政治上会有分歧，但我们有共同关心的事物，
that are going to have to bring us together. George Marshall is the author of Don't Even Think About It. Why are brains are wired to ignore climate change? George, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. You're very welcome. I enjoyed it. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
这些事物将不得不把我们聚拢在一起。乔治·马歇尔是《想都别想：为什么大脑会忽视气候变化》一书的作者。乔治，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。不客气。我很享受。谢谢你。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Lauren Embry. I first met Lauren a few years ago in Dallas. I quickly learned she has a deep interest in social science research, especially as it applies to social justice issues.
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、瑞安·卡茨、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是劳伦·埃姆里。几年前我在达拉斯第一次见到劳伦。我很快了解到她对社会科学研究有着浓厚的兴趣，尤其是当它应用于社会正义问题时。
Lauren and the Embry Family Foundation were early backers of the Hidden Brain Project and they provided some of the first dollars that got this podcast off the ground. If you like Hidden Brain, you have Lauren to thank, as do we. If you like our work, please consider supporting us. You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳伦和埃姆里家族基金会是《隐藏的大脑》项目的早期支持者，他们提供了最早的一笔资金，让这个播客得以起步。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，你得感谢劳伦，我们也是。如果你喜欢我们的工作，请考虑支持我们。你可以在 support.hiddenbrain.org 上进行支持。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。下周见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。